>> NORMAL FOLK LIKE US.
HUNT US FOR SPORT.
>> Raymond: WE WERE THE FIRST TO
TELL YOU THAT ABOUT THE NBC
UNIVERSAL MOVIE.
NOW THEY'RE FACING BACKLASH FOR
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
CONTROVERSIAL FILM "THE HUNT".
THE FILM IS ABOUT WEALTHY
LIBERALS HUNTING AND KILLING
DEPLORABLES ON A DESERVE.
THE FILM PULLED THE ADS AFTER
THE DAYTON AND EL PASO
SHOOTINGS.
THERE'S NO PLANS TO MOVE THE
RELEASE.
WILL THIS BE A DECISION THEY
COME TO REGRET?
JOINING ME IS ACTOR ROBERT
DOBBY.
YOU STARRED IN DIEHARD, THE BOND
MOVIES.
NBC SAYS THIS IS A SATIRE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS FILM BEING
RELEASED THIS MOMENT.
>> THE CULTURAL IMPACT --
HOLLYWOOD HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
ON ITS CULTURAL IMPACT TO
SOCIETY.
WE JUST SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
DAYTON, OHIO, TEXAS.
WHAT WE SAW HAPPEN IN LAS VEGAS,
A SHOOTING GALLERY FOR SOMEONE.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, CULTURE, I
LIKE THAT.
I LIKE PEOPLE EXPRESSING
THEMSELVES.
THERE'S THIS RESPONSIBILITY TO
CULTURE.
HOW MANY KIDS ARE -- WHO KNOW
WHOSE WILL KIDNAP WHO AND SAY
LET'S HAVE FUN.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THE FILM.
I HEARD THE CONTROVERSY ABOUT
IT.
THE FILM MAKERS HAVE BEEN
CONTROVERSIAL BEFORE.
"COMPLIANCE" WAS ABOUT A FEMALE
BEING ABUSED IN A McDONALD'S OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
PEOPLE OF SUNDANCE WALKED OUT ON
IT.
JASON BLOOM AND HIS COMPANY DID
"WHIPLASH."
IT WAS A FINANCIAL FAILURE BUT
WON THE OSCAR.
THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY IN OUR
BUSINESS TO NOT HAVE THIS --
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN.
>> WHEN WE KNOW THESE MASS
SHOOTERS RESPOND TO VIOLENT
IMAGERY, TO SET UP A PICTURE
WHERE YOU HAVE AMERICANS HUNTING
OTHER AMERICANS -- THE PRESIDENT
TALKED ABOUT THE HUNT TODAY.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT RACIST?
HOLLYWOOD IS RACIST.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH THE KIND
OF MOVIES THEY'RE PUTTING OUT IS
VERY DANGEROUS FOR OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT HOLLYWOOD IS DOING IS A
TREMENDOUS DISSERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> ROBERT DAVI, THE FILM MAKERS
OF "THE HUNT" SAID THE
DEPLORABLES TURNED THE TABLE THE
ON THEM.
ISN'T THIS POLITICAL MURDER?
HOMICIDE.
>> IT'S WRONG BOTH WAYS.
IMAGINE HAVING A FILM WHERE
PEOPLE ARE KIDNAPPING MUSLIMS OR
BLACK PEOPLE OR ITALIANS AND
HAVING A SHOOTING GALLERY.
OR JEWS.
IT'S A NO-WIN FILM.
WE SHOULDN'T BE PROPAGATING THAT
INTO SOCIETY.
IT'S SO DANGEROUS.
PEOPLE OUT THERE IN OUR SOCIETY
HAVE PROBLEMS.
THE MENTAL ILLNESS.
THIS WILL AFFECT SOMEONE AND
SOMEONE WILL -- WHO KNOWS WHAT
MIGHT GENERATE FROM THIS FILM.
IT'S NOT THE KIND OF
ENTERTAINMENT WE SHOULD BE
DOING.
>> WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THE
RHETORIC THAT PEOPLE USE AND HOW
THAT LEADS TO BAD ENDS.
WHY ISN'T SOMETHING LIKE THIS
CONSIDERED A VARIABLE HERE?
WE HAVE TO MOVE ON TO THIS
UPROAR --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT LENIN SAID
ABOUT CINEMA.
IT WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT TOOL
FOR PROPAGANDA.
>> Raymond: LET'S PRAY IT'S NOT.
I FEAR YOU'RE RIGHT.
ROBERT, I WANT TO MOVE ON TO
THIS UPROAR OVER STEPHEN ROSS.
HE HOSTED THE BIG FUND RAISER
FOR TRUMP TODAY.
A FEW PROTESTERS LINED THE
STREETS OUTSIDE HIS HAMPTON
NEW YORK, HOME.
THE REAL BACKLASH COMES FROM
CELEBRITIES LIKE MICHAEL MOORE
AND CHRISSY TEIGEN CALLING FOR
PEOPLE TO CANCEL THEIR
MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE ROSS IS AN
INVESTOR IN THOSE GYMS.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
HOW IS CANCELLING A GYM
MEMBERSHIP STOP AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU MIGHT
DISAGREE WITH?
>> AGAIN, IT'S THE WRONG IDEA.
WE CAN'T BE DOING THIS TO EACH
OTHER IN THE NATION.
WE SHOULD BE DOING THINGS TO
UNIFY.
YOU MEAN TO TELL ME ANYONE THAT
SUPPORTS SOMEBODY ELSE AND GIVES
MONEY TO A CAMPAIGN -- THIS IS
TAKING IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
GEORGE SOROS, HOW MUCH MONEY HAS
HE GIVEN TO PEOPLE?
THE KOCH BROTHERS.
HOW MUCH MONEY BOB IGER FROM
DISNEY GIVEN TO THE DEMOCRATS?
ARE WE GOING TO START BOYCOTTING
EVERY BUSINESS THAT GIVES MONEY
HERE AND THERE?
IT'S A NO-WIN SITUATION.
I DISAGREE WITH IT.
YOU DO WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
>> Raymond: IT'S THE
POLITICIZATION OF EVERYTHING.
THE PRESIDENT HAULED IN $12
MILLION.
ACTOR ARMY HAMMER IS ALSO
JUMPING ON THE SHAME TRAIN.
HE'S CALLING OUT A MAJOR
EXECUTIVE SUPPORTING TRUMP
TWEETING, HEY, WHILE EVERYONE
SEEMS TO BE ON EQUINOX THINGS,
ONE OF TRUMP'S LARGEST DONORS IS
HEAD OF MARVEL.
SEEMS TO ME THIS IS THE REAL
HUNT.
AN ATTEMPT TO PURGE ANY ONE FROM
HOLLYWOOD THAT MIGHT SUPPORT
SOMEONE THAT THE MAJORITY
DISAGREES WITH THERE.
>> I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD GOINGLE
ARM AND HAMMER THAT SAID TO AL
GORE SENIOR, I WILL MAKE YOUR
SEASON AL JR. PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I MEAN, THERE'S A CULTURE.
I MET ARM AND HAMMER.
HE'S A NICE GUY.
BUT THIS IS FREEDOM.
WHAT HAPPENS TO DEMOCRACY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO OUR
DEMOCRACY, PEOPLE ARE AFRAID --
IF THEY -- IF KIDS ARE AFRAID TO
VOTE OR SPEAK THEIR MIND, IT
DOES HAVE AN EFFECT.
THESE CELEBRITIES HAVE AN
EFFECT.
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO DO THAT.
>> Raymond: BEFORE I LET YOU GO,
30 SECOND.
TELL ME QUICKLY ABOUT THIS CORE
IDEA YOU HAVE ALMOST A
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH AS A RESULT
OF THESE MASS SHOOTINGS.
>> WELL, SINCE 2001, I WAS ON
THE HOMELAND SECURITY POLICY
INSTITUTE.
WHEN I SAW THINGS HAPPENING AND
PEOPLE NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO, I
CAME UP TO DO A WHITE PAPER TO
PROTECT THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE SOFT
TARGETS OF AMERICA.
BASED ON THOSE GUYS IN
PENNSYLVANIA TOOK THE PLANE AND
WENT INTO THE GROUND.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN HELP
THIS NATION.
THE WOMAN IN SAN DIEGO THAT SAW
SOMETHING AND WAS AFRAID TO SAY
IT PAUSE OF POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
A CIVILIAN PATROL -- IT'S MORE
THAN 30 SECONDS.
IT'S NOT WEAPONRY.
IT'S AN INTELLIGENCE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES TO WORK WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THEY'RE SENSITIZED, SMALL
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE NEED EYES AND EARS THAT WILL